foreign
the purpose of Art is to wash every
day's life's dust over our souls
I always deeply believed this Picasso
statement
arts and more broadly the beauty I find
in an object in nature or even in a
cherished Bittersweet memory has this
transcending power over me that puts me
in a core mindset where I find new ideas
put by these forces I even formed a
friendship with a painting once
I was 14 years old a foreign student in
New York City and it was the first time
I stayed away from my family
respect to my Hungarian home everything
just felt so cold and Tall alienating
The Continuous Rush of people and cars
in Manhattan and English language I
barely spoke
all made me feel isolated
my way after school led by the
Metropolitan Museum and I ended up
wondering its galleries daily
in the Silence of these early afternoons
new words opened as I walked from room
to room
and when I met these two ladies
I felt I can tell them anything
day after day I was sitting in front of
this painting admiring its swirling
colors the harmonies while I shared my
innermost secrets with them
I wasn't alone anymore
Art became my last resort this place of
deep Humanity an outlet for thoughts and
emotions
so you can imagine my disgust when I
hear about this new revolutionary type
of art generative air
I mean not this don't misunderstand me I
love technology but you can take away
the last stronghold of humanity
I felt my core values were attacked
so I turned to the first solution at
hand
can you create an original piece do you
have creativity
well the answer wasn't really helping I
decided I need to dig deeper I wanted to
understand what is exactly the
collaboration between machine and humans
and where is the front line of human
creativity
instead of scientific articles what I
found were countless fearing using click
provoking headlines talking about
doomsday scenarios how AI is here to
take over our lives
it wasn't helpful
so in my desperation I turned to art
history
and I had to realize that generative art
is nothing new it's been around since
the 60s
generative art simply means that the
artist uses a predetermined system for
example a computer program
and coding becomes the new creative
medium
in this sense the coding script is
nothing else
but a new type of Paintbrush drawing
Strokes with lines of code
now in today's AI models there are two
revolutionary changes
first is the first time that these
models do not work based on a set of
rules set by us
instead they are showing the large data
sets they are shown examples and results
and they come up with their own patterns
their own rules
now as you can imagine this is a fastly
developing field but what most experts
believe that the main difference comes
down to pattern recognition
why these models break down an image and
rebuild it line by line bit by bit from
Bottoms Up
what we humans do is something very
different
we first
guess the outline the larger picture
and we assign a meaning
and then we fill in the details to match
that meaning that we guessed
do you see a rabbit
or do you see a duck
and now you know what is the root cause
to all of our biases
the second biggest difference just comes
down to the sheer amount of data
the amount of information that these
models Aggregate and build upon is just
unprecedented
to compare traditional Arts to
generative art in this sense it's just
like to compare photography to painting
the human eye cannot capture and analyze
to that level of detail that a camera
lens can
and similarly our mind is incapable of
aggregating this amount of information
and this is a huge opportunity
just imagine
Monet the great impressionist painter
instead of sitting in his own garden
painting his favorite water lilies
would have been able to Glimpse across
the globe and across time and see all
the different kinds of water lilies and
see also the paintings and sculptures
even music and literature dedicated to
this flower
and Drew his inspiration
from all of that
what could have happened
would we see different color palettes
and impressionism would we see different
shapes
would we see water least tall and floaty
like in Botswana or represented as Tiny
rectangles like in Japan
what could have happened
so does this mean that these models can
create such captivating pieces as we can
well
let's think about it for a second
when do we call it something creative
something creative
is something unexpected
it's when we are surprised
and surprise comes when those inner
details do not match the meaning we are
signed
by definition there cannot be surprised
in derived knowledge that builds on a
set of rules
and that is what AI is
so why all this fear
and what are we afraid of
don't these cycles and narratives to
sound awfully familiar
200 years ago photography induced
similar fear-provoking commentary and as
you know today photography did not end
the era of painting
but it is fewer new art movements
photography ended up expanding what we
thought creatively was possible what
painters were able to do
money's own impressionist movement was
born as a direct reaction to photography
so the ultimate question remains
does this mean these models will ever
create like we do
well
replicating a human mind goes Way Beyond
replicating pattern recognition
how human thoughts rise is still
somewhat new to us
but what we know is that our minds feed
on fat experiences
as well as thousands of years of joint
learning as species
and some of these experiences are really
difficult to explain
how would you describe to trade GPT how
you know how it feels to ride a bike
or how it feels to learn how to swim
and on the subconscious learning studies
in epigenetics actually showed that some
of these experiences program part of our
genes and we pass these On to the Next
Generation
what this means is that what you would
think how you face the situation will be
completely different from the person
next to you
but what all these fields agree on is
that new thoughts creative ideas come
when we feel safe
when we feel calm
when we can make the best sense of the
world around us
learning this made me realize why so
many years ago those two girls helped me
through the depths of homesickness and
helped me come up with new ideas to face
my situation
so it's time
it's time we change the fear narrative
and thought to talk about how we can use
these new tools to further stretch the
capability of our creativity
and who knows maybe these tools will
also help me to have a more adult
conversation with my all-time friends
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]